il mio lavoro consiste nel dare una
forma visiva dati e informazioni
lo faccio progettando visualizzazioni
che aiutino i lettori a esplorare temi
complessi nella loro completezza queste
che vedete sono alcune delle mie
visualizzazioni caratterizzate da
diversi livelli di complessità amo
prestare moltissima attenzione ai più
piccoli dettagli e come potete
immaginare
tra gli organi di senso che utilizzo di
più nel mio lavoro
ci sono chiaramente gli occhi ma nel
maggio del 2012
a un certo punto dal mio occhio sinistro
ho iniziato a vedere così in quei giorni
mi è stata diagnosticata un'infezione
alla cornea rischiavo di perdere la
vista dall'occhio sinistro da cui in
quel momento vedevo solamente una
macchia bianca e non sapevo se la
condizione sarebbe stata temporanea o
permanente perché dipendeva dalla mia
reazione alle cure se ripenso a quei
giorni c'è un'immagine molto distinta
che mi viene in mente un ricordo io in
piedi davanti a una rivista tenuta in
mano dai miei genitori con l'occhio
destro l'occhio sano coperto e l'occhio
sinistro messo alla prova era una sorta
di rituale quotidiano lo facevamo tutti
i giorni per cercare di capire se stessi
effettivamente riacquistando la vista o
meno
e ricordo molto bene il riaffiorare
degli elementi visivi e dei dettagli che
giorno dopo giorno diventavano sempre di
più e sempre più definiti ho
riacquistato gran parte della vista nel
corso dei mesi ma non tutta c'è ancora
una piccola cicatrice nel mio occhio
sinistro che mi impedisce di vedere
perfettamente ma decisamente molto bene
anche perché compenso con l'occhio
destro ed è ironico ed è vero ora lo
trovo sia ironico e anche un po
divertente perché sono una visual
designer la cui vista non è più perfetta
lo sarà mai più questo evento ha avuto
ovviamente un certo impatto sulla mia
vita in generale ma anche sul mio
approccio al lavoro
quindi che cosa è cambiato come vi
dicevo mi occupo di dare una forma ai
dati mi sono accorta che questo evento
ha avuto due impatti principali sul mio
approccio al lavoro prima di tutto
nonostante la mia vista non più perfetta
ho acquisito una maggiore sensibilità ai
dettagli visivi passo molto tempo a
cercare ispirazione per i miei progetti
e mi accorgo di ricercare quegli
elementi e quei dettagli che possano
aiutarmi a creare un legame con gli
occhi e con la mente dei lettori
un po come dettagli che emergevano dalla
rivista lo creavano con i miei con i
miei occhi
vi voglio mostrare un esempio una
visualizzazione realizzata per il
corriere della sera in particolare per
la lettura
l'inserto culturale del corriere ma
prima una promessa importante la lettura
un supplemento culturale s nel fine
settimana queste sono le immagini
tipiche che i lettori postano sui social
leggera la lettura è un atto lento calmo
rilassato e sapere questo conoscere il
contesto di utilizzo
mi permette di lavorare a
visualizzazioni che necessitano di tempo
per essere lette con calma un po come un
lungo articolo di giornale
in questo caso avevo visualizzato avevo
deciso divisi scusate di visualizzare le
emissioni di co2
vent'anni di emissioni di co2 in 40
paesi
questo è il dataset da cui sono partite
il passaggio dai dati alle forme e è un
processo che ha 22 elementi principali
da cui parto prima di tutto ovviamente i
dati che studio e analizzo per cercare
di capire quale sia il modo migliore per
visualizzarli e poi c'è proprio questo
momento di ispirazione visiva in cui
emerge la mia sensibilità ai dettagli in
questo caso avevo trovato questa
immagine che trovavo molto bella ma
anche vagamente inquietante per le
sfumature i colori e ho deciso di
partire da quest immagine per definire i
dettagli visivi del mio progetto
come vi dicevo per ogni nazione o
visualizzato 20 anni e di emissioni di
co2
ogni raggio che vedete rappresenta un
anno e la lunghezza di questi petali
rappresentano le tonnellate di co2
emesse o poi lavorato molto sulle
sfumature sulle texture e su dettagli
proprio ispirata da quell'immagine e sui
colori usandoli come guida per aiutare
la lettura della visualizzazione il blu
indica una diminuzione delle emissioni
rispetto all'anno precedente il rosso un
aumento
io poi ho aggiunto un altro elemento di
analisi in più un altro dato la
percentuale di consumo di energie
rinnovabili nel 1992 e nel 2012
questa è la visualizzazione finale in
cui ho visualizzato tutti i vari dati
raggruppandoli per nazione come vedete
ci sono elementi che emergono subito
come la dimensione di alcune nazioni e
tenere questa possibilità è fondamentale
ma ci sono anche le menti che
necessitano di più tempo per essere
eletti non penso che questo sia un
problema io penso che ci siano temi che
meritano di essere letti con calma
quando il contesto di utilizzo lo
consente ma c'è un'altra cosa che è
cambiata
oltre questa sensibilità visiva ed è la
ricerca per un livello aggiuntivo
qualcosa che vada oltre la vista mi
trovo spesso a cercare una componente
personale e quando possibile anche
emotiva ti accompagni i miei progetti
amo molto il teatro come attrice e
autrice e un po di tempo fa ho
sperimentato combinandolo con la data
visualization ho scritto un pezzo
teatrale e lo ha portato in scena
accompagnandolo con queste
visualizzazioni che mostravano quello
che stava accadendo sul palco usando le
forme come amplificatori visivi e nel
corso dei mesi e degli anni ho
continuato a lavorare sul potenziale
espressivo delle forme visive con il
fine di utilizzarlo per trattare temi
rilevanti e questo è il motivo per cui
ho iniziato a parlare a lavorare al
progetto di cui vi parlerò ora è un
progetto personale senza commissione e
si tratta senza dubbio del progetto
emotivamente più intensa qui abbia mai
lavorato un paio di anni fa il mio
fidanzato mi ha raccontato di un ragazzo
che aveva conosciuto
un richiedenti asilo arrivato dalla
somalia che chiacchierando con lui gli
aveva parlato del suo viaggio dalla sua
città natale all'italia sentirli parlare
mi ha fatto pensare a come i media
italiani tendano a focalizzarsi sulla
traversata del mediterraneo
ma ci sono spesso centinaia di giorni di
viaggio migliaia di chilometri che
precedono quel tratto ho iniziato subito
a pensare a come mi sarebbe piaciuto
utilizzare le mie competenze per parlare
di questi viaggi visualizzando dati ad
essi legati
mesi dopo ha incontrato una volontaria
che lavora in un centro di accoglienza e
le ho parlato della mia idea lei
fortunatamente l'amata subito mi ha
detto che aveva già in mente un gruppo
di persone che avrebbero potuto
parteciparvi ed è stato così che ho
conosciuto mbs smd a lsg e tk 6
richiedenti asilo arrivati in italia nel
ed è così che è nato the stories bianca
line una narrazione visiva dei loro
viaggi li ho incontrati in un centro di
accoglienza a vercelli che è la mia
città natale e il mio scopo era proprio
quello di dare una forma percepibile ai
loro viaggi durante i nostri incontri
abbiamo ricostruito le rotte punto per
punto con l'aiuto di google maps e per
ogni tappa
ho chiesto loro quanti giorni di viaggio
erano serviti per arrivarvi quali mezzi
di trasporto avevano utilizzato e quanti
giorni di viaggio vi erano rimasti
quanti giorni vi erano rimasti prima di
spostarsi alla tappa successiva
in più ho detto loro che avrei annotato
qualunque dato informazione che
avrebbero voluto aggiungere commento al
loro racconto questo processo di
raccolta dati è stato ovviamente
completamente diversa da quelli a cui
sono abituate solitamente a cerco dati
online ma per una volta ho deciso di
uscire da questo mondo digitale in cui
sono anche troppo immersa per incontrare
e parlare con le persone che vivono il
tema ogni giorno e
in questa situazione penso onestamente
che i miei sentimenti e il mio punto di
vista fossero totalmente irrilevanti se
confrontati con i loro ma voglio
condividere con voi qualche riflessione
proprio perché questo processo di
raccolta è stato particolarmente
significativo chiedere alle sei persone
di raccontare a me un'estranea le loro
esperienze non è stato facile non a
causa loro sono stati tutti
incredibilmente gentili chiari e
disponibili ma perché sentivo questo
generico sensi di colpa per chiedere
loro di rivivere queste esperienze così
dolorose raccontando mele a un certo
punto però uno di loro mi ha detto è
importante che conoscono queste storie
ed è così
è importante che si conoscono queste
storie ho scelto appositamente
richiedere informazioni dati molto
semplici perché volevo proprio fornire
un racconto che fosse chiaro semplice e
razionale e questo per me è un punto
focale
io credo che un tema così complesso
meriti razionalità e anche una chiarezza
semplice l'essere comunicato
adeguatamente dopo i nostri incontri ho
lavorato alle visualizzazioni
ho deciso di disegnare per ognuno di
loro una linea che fosse unica e
plasmata dalle esperienze vissute i
giorni di viaggio sono rappresentati da
una linea orizzontale blu prigioni di
permanenza azzurra tre giorni di viaggio
da una tappa all'altra e ho utilizzato
diverse linee tratteggiate per
rappresentare i diversi mezzi di
trasporto
il progetto finale è un sito story
behind al ain dot.com non sono una
sviluppatrice quindi per realizzarlo ha
collaborato con il mio carissimo collega
bravissima talentuosissimo amico alex
piacentini nella home
potete vedere le sei iniziali dei
narratori e le 6
ogni singola storia è preziosa e per
questo motivo volevo essere sicura di
dare alle linee il loro spazio
mostrandole all'inizio come linee nere
su sfondo bianco interagendo con la
visualizzazione poi possibile vedere e
leggere i giorni di viaggio i mezzi di
trasporto e le città attraversate e
cliccando sui cerchi rossi è possibile
leggere i commenti più dettagliati dei
narratori
quella che vedete è la linea ds un
ragazzo di vent'anni partito dal mali è
arrivato in italia quasi quattro anni
dopo aver lasciato la sua città natale e
poi possibile vedere le mappe dietro
queste linee la parte cerchiata che
vedete rappresenta la traversata del
mediterraneo e come vedete è solo un
piccolo frammento di questa linea così
lunga
questo racconto molto semplice e senza
immagini per volere per rispettare
l'anonimato dei narratori mostra e
racconta il tema delle migrazioni da un
punto di vista molto specifico e
ovviamente fondamentale parlare di un
tema così complesso e globale mostrando
grandi numeri anche per fornire una
visione di insieme e per non lasciare
che le persone rimangano intrappolate
nelle paure che troppe figure ora stanno
sfruttando ma allo stesso tempo penso
che anche fornire uno scorcio così
personale piccolo da qui a osservarlo
possa aiutare lei capirlo in profondità
senza perdere di vista l'umanità che vi
sta dietro allo stesso tempo non penso
che la razionalità implichi
necessariamente una mancanza di empatia
e abbiamo molto bisogno di empatia ora
questo progetto è stato visto da molte
persone più di quanto mi aspettassi
onestamente e molti hanno dimostrato di
vedere queste linee con gli occhi e con
la mente commentandole facendo
trasparire una profonda comprensione una
grande empatia molte persone non si
aspettavano di vedere
linee così lunghe o riscoprire di
traversate nel deserto fatte a piedi
e i commenti dei narratori hanno
commosso molte persone come quello di sg
un ragazzo di 26 anni arrivato dal
pakistan che alla fine del nostro
incontro mi ha detto la mia mente è
tranquilla io sono tranquillo perché
sono al sicuro e per questo amo l'italia
[Applauso]
non ringrazierò mai abbastanza i sei
ragazzi per aver deciso di fidarsi di me
per aver condiviso con me le loro storie
questo applauso va a loro
queste sei linee hanno dietro sei storie
molto complesse ma ognuno alla propria
linea e la propria storia complessa o
meno che sia qualche settimana fa
preparando questo talk ho deciso di
provare a visualizzare anche le vostre
linee così da poter disegnare le vostre
storie sono linee parziali ovviamente
gli ho chiesto di indicarmi tre città in
cui siete stati che per voi sono
particolarmente significative più la
quarta da qui non siete mai passati ma
che vorreste visitare gli ho chiesto
dati sul tempo trascorso in questa città
e sui sentimenti che legate a questi
posti
io ho visualizzato queste informazioni
queste sono le vostre linee nelle vostre
storie visualizzate disegnate e questa è
la mappa dietro le vostre linee questi
elementi visivi sono significativi non
perché siano esteticamente piacevoli o
meno ma perché hanno delle persone
dietro e perché danno una voce a queste
persone
dare voce a chi non ha piattaforme penso
possa essere un buon modo per me di fare
questo lavoro
credo che la mia ricerca nel mondo della
data visualization di qualcosa che vada
oltre la vista possa trovare molti
spunti in questa direzione
voglio concludere dicendo una cosa anche
se ovvia dobbiamo vedere con gli occhi e
con la mente la vista è uno strumento
molto importante e io lo sto molto bene
ma abbiamo chiaramente bisogno di una
vista ulteriore in quanto a me sono
profondamente grata per il mio occhio
guarito e anche molto molto affezionata
alla mia piccola cicatrice che sotto
molti aspetti ha cambiato il mio modo di
vedere le cose
grazie
sì
[Applauso]
[Musica]